chiffres estimez vous qu'il y à de la
discrimination dans la nomination aux
oscars c'est la question la dernière
qu'on vous pose sur twitter parce que
justement sur twitter il ya un torrent
de critiques par rapport aux nominations
pour la course aux statuettes qui aura
lieu le 28 février prochain
alors dans la catégorie meilleur film et
meilleur réalisateur par exemple qui
compte cinq candidats bien il n'y a
qu'une seule femme
aucune femme pour les catégories de film
en langue étrangère pour la france
ailleurs ce sont les misérables de la
geely qui est nominée et il n'y a pas
beaucoup de représentants de la
diversité alors qui est en cause c'est
bien voici la réponse de la réalisatrice
patricia riggen final tel procès jean
mathieu est ce que les oscars sont
vraiment le symbole de la discrimination
alors écoutez cette année parce que
l'année dernière il y a eu
c'était donc un acteur noir récompensé
le film green book parlait aussi
finalement de cette discrimination dans
un état du sud
cette année c'est en fait c'est un peu
la grille bref c'est un peu caricatural
de temps en temps aux états unis parce
qu'alice histoire de quotas ils sont
pris maintenant les pieds dans le tapis
parce que il est vrai qu'il ya eu des
très très bons films cette année
sortie à hollywood quand on voit la
sélection des films et des réalisateurs
elle est incroyable parce qu'il ya que
du tarantino il ya du scorsese et il ya
bong joon ho mais bong joon ho la basse
et un sud coréen voilà donc il n'est pas
encore dans la politique de quotas
américaine cette année il ya une actrice
noire nommée pourquoi les nommer les
nommer pour un film sur une esclave qui
s'est échappé d'une plantation qui
ensuite à sauver d'autres esclaves donc
finalement un peu dans une caricature ce
que reproche beaucoup d'acteurs noirs
c'est qu'on ne leur donne pas des rôles
de monsieur madame tout le monde
en fait c'est ça c'est toujours la même
chose c'est toujours par rapport à l'
esclavage qu'on leur donne des
nominations et il est vrai que cette
année c'est difficile d'avoir cette
conversation parce que il ya eu
d'énormément de bons films et pas
forcément avec deux cartes avec des
acteurs ou des actrices noir mais ça
reste quand même assez difficile mais
c'est intéressant d'avoir justement
cette cahier cette conversation parce
que c'est justement pour voir si on peut
les sortir un peu de la complication et
quand il ya peu de complexité comme des
polémiques georges et les progressistes
de l'hudson trois conservateurs mais en
fait ce qui est un drame de la france et
la progression du communautarisme à
l'américaine et la mesure de savoir qui
et quel pourcentage de chivu crois et je
suis français je suis pas je refuse de
jouer la catégorie des états unis et et
oui vous avez très bien dit ça ça dépend
des années
moi je suis choqué par leur système de
quotas dans les universités c'est assez
racialiste les noirs entendent point les
asiatiques ont moins de points laisse
passer c'est vraiment n'importe quoi
la fois la plus française et une
indivisible et heureusement pour eux
cette année on va les sauver puisqu'on
va voir l'excellent spike lee qui sera
président du jury à cannes
donc voilà la france réalisateur la
france veut sauver les états unis sur
leurs quotas béatrice hess qui a pas
trop tendance à idéaliser que si un peu
mais sans doute qu'il fallait aussi tiré
la sonnette d'alarmé sur lève que les
femmes réalisatrices commence à faire un
peu de bruit et se fassent entendre ces
instants les stars ne faudrait il ya
laissé la vie
les acteurs bon peut-être mais c'est pas
cet arbre qui va créer chez toute la
forêt de toutes les autres donc il y a
encore besoin de se faire entendre
moi je suis aussi absolument contre des
quotas ça n'a pas de sens bon voilà des
bons films doivent être primé au bout
femmes et puis et puis c'est tout ceci
étant on voit bien que dans le cinéma
accorder de la place aux femmes assez
partagé ce qu'on n'avait pas l'habitude
de partager
alors ça monte en puissance et ça va
prendre du temps peut-être l'année
prochaine il y aura des réalisatrices et
des actrices qui font ce que des gens
n'en ai déjà pour une égalité salariale
sur les plates-bandes oui parce que
c'est ça qui est incroyable c'est que
certaines femmes certaines comédiennes
très connus sont moins payées que les
hommes dans des blockbusters
hollywoodiens elles arriveront comme les
joueuses de tennis
alexis d'un autre côté on comprend moins
seul quand même cette polémique parce
que s'il ya bien un lieu où il n'y a pas
de discrimination positive ou négative
c'est quand même la plupart du temps
c'est le seul cinéma là pour le sur ce
point je rejoins le relais mais sûrement
les quotas en matière d'emploi
d'éducation le truc
franchement je n'ai pas ma tasse de thé
mais en matière d'art à la question de
savoir ce qu'ils gagnent les blancs
noirs jaunes verts ou bleus que tahar
ben si on va saisir
c'est ce qu'a suffisamment oui m'enfin
c'est l'idée d'aller mesurer une oeuvre
artistique à loum de l'origine des gens
qui sont impliqués de danse acompte de
danseurs dont on tourne on sait
peut-être que le système c'est ce que
disait
la personne que vous aviez interview
peut-être que là les propositions faites
aux femmes sont reconnues
d'ailleurs c'est pas tant les femmes que
l'aide de surface il bien compris le
seul reproche qu'on faisait à hollywood
cette année cette série mais mais ce
qu'on dit c'est il n'y a pas assez de
2,2 de diversité peut pas venu parmi les
nominés de 7 ans mais moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la qualité des films
si le film est bon glémaud ses films est
mauvaise il ya enfin on nous on nous
serine analysant faut séparer le dans
d'autres polémiques l'homme de l'oeuvre
d'art etc
et là on va tout mesurer à l'aune de
savoir qui fait quoi
vous imaginez le prix goncourt alors
proust alors c'est un homme
asus a ouai mais il est juif ah ouais
c'est pas mal ayant baissé l'homosexuel
d'accord mais enfin qu'est ce que c'est
que cette matinée se manière de penser
c'est pas la question
la recherche c'est ce que nos confrères
adrien va-tout de marianne dit quand
même là en plus le problème c'est que
l'équipe le métier de critique de cinéma
va se transformer en des compteurs d'eau
minorité très américain ici c'est pas
non c'est logique quand un film de
scorsese avec de niro forme id et elle
peut de chine au on ne peut pas vraiment
lutter c'est ce que nous dit d'ailleurs
les deux rôles al pacino c'est pas du
web
après il ya une question qui se pose la
comédienne française aïssa maïga avait
écrit un livre l'année dernière qui
s'appelait noir n'est pas mon métier et
les jeunes sur l'un des rôles de noirs
voilà c'est à dire que je n'aurais pas
par un rôle de chef d'entreprise voilà
c'est parce que possible un arsène lupin
noir et ben oui tout à fait avec omar sy
oui voilà ça commence on doit donc la
vache en mai mais elle a écrit son livre
l'année dernière et donc elle par
exemple c'est ça c'est la même pour les
matières proposées beaucoup de femmes
blanches en plus d'être chef dans toi
qui tu as fait c'est le jeu
il ya plein drôle de nom mais c'est pas
tout et en tout cas il ya autant de
femmes que d'hommes dans les films
générale il ya des très grandes actrices
et je crois pas que notamment pause
histoire de salaire c'est pas du ctpa du
sexisme même si bien du sexisme donc
cinéma c'est qu'est-ce qui le cinéma
c'est une machine à faire de l'argent et
on paye un acteur s'y rapportent
et le jour où quand une femme fait venir
plus de gens des salles qu'un homme ait
levé les mieux payés je crois pas que il
ya des gens qui extraient se disent on
va moins bien payés les femmes
pas du tout estimez vous qu'il y à de la
discrimination dans les nominations aux
oscars non à 61 points 5 % sont en tout
cas ce qu'ont répondu nos internautes
sur twitter on s'honore d'avoir en
plateau une femme qui était chef
directrice de la revue hérodote
géopolitique du sahel et du sahara
c'était hérodote il ya un an mais ça n'a
pas pris une ride avec notamment une
analyse de l'intervention militaire
française par marc pérouse de montclos
dans ce numéro puis le dernier numéro
lui est consacré à l'allemagne
et bien sûr vous retrouvez demain le
figaro vous oubliez pas 6h50 1 rtl
l'affairé mathieu pernot sinon un
dimanche vous avez envie qu'ils peuvent
englober un petit peu plus tard demain
merci de nous avoir suivis vous
retrouver guillaume roquette demain même
heure même endroit